have you ever wondered how someone
becomes a u.s citizen if they're not
born in the united states attorney eric
palacios from eric palacios and
associates the sponsors of this segment
tells us four ways to gain citizenship
take a look
hi i'm eric palacios and welcome to the
legal minute the question for today is
what are the four ways to gain american
citizenship the first three are pretty
common number one birth in the usa
number two acquisition this is if you
were born outside of the us or one of
its territories but at least one of your
parents is a citizen of the united
states number three derivation if your
parents become citizens and you are
under the age of 18 you will
automatically become a citizen without
an additional application and number
four the one we think about and the one
where you most likely need an attorney
naturalization this is a specific
process and application that you have to
complete generally after three or five
years of being a legal resident in the
united states
thank you for joining us on the legal
minute don't forget to download my free
app eric palacio's legal app and we'll
see you next time
and for more information you can give
eric palacios and associates a call at
702-444-7777